salle youtube et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle vidéo salle vlad ça le kfc le
tout le monde
aujourd'hui c'est une très bonne journée
parce que on va pas se mouiller
non juste une très bonne journée c'est
tout ça comme c'est cool donc voilà je
sais pas sur quelle chaîne jean-claude
cette vidéo juste comme tout le monde se
pose la question que l'on me le demande
je vais le redire sur une vidéo et un
petit problème avec maccione perso on
sait pas encore ce qu'il en est mais ça
devrait revenir rapidement d'ailleurs
peut-être que cette vidéo et même sur
cette chaîne en tout cas on attend des
réponses de youtube et bon ben on va
parler de ce qui nous intéresse c'est à
dire la partie mvl mamediarov numéro 2
au wii donc pas surprenant ça commençait
par quatre puisque maxime on joue avec
les bancs d'un centre est très
prévisible aussi que les toits moi je
pensais qu'ils occupent les six est très
possible sur les solides parce que c'est
ça l'idée que tu mènes avec le score 1 0
ça te fait penser à de telles choses
quand laissé 6eme pas n'ont pas foulé 5
parce que beaucoup des lignes solides
notés possible donc beaucoup de choses à
prévoir les vrais entrouverte
puis les variables classique de
l'espagnol ya tant de possibilités donc
faussée 4 c'est surtout pour limiter les
mettez le choix de l'adversaire pour ne
pas se perdre dans les préparations
avant les parties en quelque sorte de
ses écrits parce que justement avec le
score moins 1 fois 5 hockey ici c'est
digne d'un petit commentaire
les derniers temps glas
ce cri hier à employer souvent les
lignes korolev 6-2 3-6 tir que des six
ce 3e set je suppose qu les lignes très
intéressante les modernes dynamiques
tout il est d'ailleurs un moment donné
détruits maxime des autres parties
rapides les reins signifie qu'après
l'année dernière - e
bien sûr ça se comprend que c'est pas
pour aujourd'hui donc faut ce centre
était prévisible
ouais après ses trois choristes quoi se
créèrent a employé plusieurs variantes
le plus souvent avec à 6 2 6
puis il a essayé les lignes avec 2,5
d'un coup peut-être pas maintenant mais
les rings qu'il a employé plus tard dans
cette partie il va lui n'a jamais joué
avant donc c'était une surprise
il a préparé une surprise parce que bien
sûr il a préparé une ligne contre
l'espanyol et bien sûr l'auteur
italienne
maxime joue souvent là aussi je devais
avoir quelque chose donc on va voir
quelle surprise les préparez donc des
six petits rock h61 on va pas vous
essayer d'expliquer expliqué devons
aussi avoir ici et de vous expliquer la
fatigue pour tous les détails de
l'ouverture parce que les finesses de
ses ordres de couture ont d'abord h3
d'abord que les deux mois mais je
comprends pas donc c'est un peu
compliqué très c'est l'un des sujets les
plus compliqués aux échecs moderne bon
ashtrom alter autre erreur cash agents
la synchro la case g4 et à 5 heures la
ville at c'est justement la première
surprise de la partie et est ce que
comme tu le disais il a plutôt joué
jusqu'à présent des systèmes avec à 6
oui quand on n'a pas joué le système
avec des cinq d'un coup
au lieu de six
il a toujours mille son pion sur a6 et
c'est juste un autre univers en fait ça
change tout n'est qu'une petite case où
est depuis en place un bond à 5
en fait c'est lié à une idée que je
pense que normalement les imans les
humains n'auraient jamais trouvé mais ça
a été montré par les ordinateurs en 2016
que voilà les décors un peu de deux fous
1,6 g expliqué pendant la retransmission
en direct et indirect que si l'option
noah est déjà sur 2 à 5
les pressions après faut aussi ces feux
sont moins intéressants pour les banques
ont quoi parce que noir c'est parce que
il ya plus de avant l'âge des pions de
café je peux essayer de montrer qu'on va
dire à six qui avaient des deux fours 6
francs comprend leurs dix considèrent
que beckham on va dire foulée 6 et à
quatre ça donne l'avantagé aux blancs la
possibilité de pousser les dames
chargement direct mais l'évolution de la
position la possibilité de le faire
ah ouais tu t'étais pas tout de suite
mais plus tard mais avant en général on
parle de choisir donc à 5 c si vous
voulez c'est plutôt prophylactique mais
paquiot un au revoir sans plus tarder
car il était dos au but 6 il faut que sa
soeur emma doit donc prouver saga temps
met la pression sur le quart et c6 donc
on met la pression sur les cases des 4
et 5
ouais et ça n'a pas été considéré comme
intéressant pour le noir avant que les
ordinateurs nous ont montré une réplique
de l'idée fameuse de rubinstein d'un
beau 8 avec l'idée damas
je crois qu'à une belle partie aussi
dans une instance viennent de garry
kasparov
oh oui mais ça a été aussi grand public
oui or et une en vigueur mais c'est
juste pour un d'ailleurs dans la défense
française il existe les manières famille
ou pour une autre réplique de lutte et
de grosses sommes d'argent j'ai eu un
vrai match c'est une des idées préférées
de fab
oui entier en fait ces projets comme
quelque sorte
pourquoi
après dans ma tête les noirs viol contre
lady cat frapper sur f2 a publié par le
groupe de rats et gagner de l'espace a
joint à 4 donc cet encours multi
fonctions fonction il y avait une partie
jouée cette année l'air entre guy
reading les autres joueurs de l'élite
fossé 6 possède des quatre décédés
forissier sexisme et à sa joue plutôt
fourcade est 6e chrétiens avec à trois
fautes de deux cavaliers de deux tours 8
bon je pense que apparemment les doigts
sont ok donc que les enfants d'un à sept
et maintenant pendant les parties
j'étais surpris par le choix de maxime
parce que récemment il y avait deux
partis jouer en cadence rapide même août
rapide puisque l'une des parties a été
un magnum pas avant le premier contre
sow cette étiquette eu des fausses et 6
passes médias le grand père le pion et
donc ses six intermédiaire des ces
intermédiaires 1 x 4 food de ohd gros
bordel leurs amateurs matériellement on
en est où les noirs peuvent gagner un
tour ça va faire deux pièces
matériellement les noirs vont être un
peu mieux
ouais mais il faut surtout pas se
dépêcher avec ce bouffon plutôt parce
que l'on peut se faire mal
ouais donc le pion ces trois peut-être à
se faire reprendre et en gros il y aura
deux pièces contre
la tour est un pion oui depuis un temps
y aurait il y aura pas y aura un deux
trois quatre cinq six sept cantons total
de 3 peut-être 5
le buteur est plutôt de savoir déjà
d'aller parti et les mains propres et
sur le jouet de ça et je pense qu'ils
ont dû le jouer selon l'oms
parce que si tu prends alors j'imagine
en juste pour montrer l'idée ça doit
être de vie devenir verges et trois et
que la dame ait commencé à converger
pour attaquer ou quelque chose comme ça
demeurant très bien passé pour être
qu'il va donc et une autre partie a été
franc de nani durée d'un deuxième pion
traduite que les histoires et après que
le set par set c'est typiquement pour un
berger 6 impossible de comprendre
pourquoi après des quatre les noirs
n'ont pris sur n'ont pas pris sur de
gamme parce que eux des 6 2 6 4
et si lad au lieu de se décaler t4 il ya
2 500 kg 4 et justement le collier très
bien placé que l'éducateur deux autres
cadres connaissent en attente entier le
5 1 millions 4,4 et connaissent un oui
et on n'a pas le temps de faire flouer 3
où est donc voilà pays ont noté les
possibilités des bois - presque tout de
suite on disait en fait c'était de faire
ça pendant le direct tu pensé à ces deux
coups pour essayer de garder du jeu
parce que maxime est dans une situation
ils étaient obligés de gagner pour
compliquer donc tu as ta pensé qu'il
avait préparé quelque chose on sait
varier entre mais lui la juge ou est fou
et 3 très rapidement très rapidement il
était dans la prépa fou prend 1,3 ou
cavaliers prend 3 en soit c'est de la
prépa cavaliers cesse alors vlad juste
on l'a on n'a pas vraiment eu le temps
de le dire mais très souvent ce cavalier
c6 il reste pendant ces six dans les
dents les italiennes et même les
espagnols
il peut être voué à aller vers g6 d'où
il protègera qui ont eu cinq et il se
préparera à venir éventuellement vers f4
et aussi parce que l epad en diable et
les poteaux chabot afin difficilement
tout jouable à quatre en fait à quatre
c'est pour gagner de l'espace parce que
je connaissais pas l'éditeur fait
pendant les parties j'étais un peu
surpris parce que je donne pour mes
enfants c'est pour gagner de l'espace
par exemple si au lieu de cela les
bourgeois 4
le coq l on avait pensé de base que
volet justice fausto en train de boire
et des gardes parce qu'on protège contre
les noirs jouent à quatre décades bessin
et prennent de l'espace avel dame pour
et après du contrôle est aussi limite
l'activité du 1 qui peut plus revenir
sur cette diagonale
ouais donc c'est pour ça qu'avant
maintenant tout le monde le collège
aussi si tu as disco
chokri hier à je dois donner très
rapidement mais qui agissent ici on
avait vu des variantes de partis qui
avaient continué les parkings à vous à
plusieurs parties avait la partie de
carson compte dink qui se termine avec
nous il y est reparti il y avait une
partie 2-2 karekin avec les doigts
compteur suffit de lire je pense que
cette tour f18 d'entre eux trois dames
ce 5 août à massy d'un mois 6,7
c'était le dos dans ce sens qu on ne
peut pas prendre sur pc parce que tout y
est les bons on fait quelque chose je me
rappelle qu'elle coupe tout en g3
quelque chose comme ça dans ces six d'un
poussin 25 après et après bruce hills le
pouvoir n'a été que de 3 et ce club
en gros si on n'est pas sûr de dire
exactement les coups on n'a pas
forcément notice est parti là mais en
gros il y avait deux parties qui se
continue avec ce même plan de m
l'adamant des saints qui ça qui est
important d'expliquer la dame qu'elle
saura si souvent ces six venez
s'échanger et les blancs jeu pour ce
petit avantage du pion b5
mais ces microscopiques avec l'idée de
faire peut-être b4 la couleur comme on a
connu ça pose moi je suis sceptique y
aura donc beaucoup moins empêche je n'ai
pas analysé cette position là donc je
peux me tromper mais moi je suis
sceptique dos tout moyen chari rajoute
aura des huit ours de soleure m'a dit et
je veux pas critiquer ce couleurs même
si je préfère que les jets six mois de
toute évidence élèves est où ta faute
d'autre idf vous paraît que des pousses
étaient quatre les bords jose de lemos
prix il faut penser qu'à voler sa carte
est maintenant le premier un moment
important
donc nous en live on s'attendait un truc
genre cavaliers g6 tête j'ai trois pour
pour jouer sur les fuites et peut-être
maxime qui remettait en place le prend
dans des trois dames assises dame b 5
on s'attendait à ok ça me laisse un coin
prime prises et b6 on s'attendait à voir
ça en fait oui et on n'arrivait pas à
comprendre si c'était vraiment grave
pour mamediarov on pensait que
ça va je suis persuadé juste - où il
s'est mis à réfléchir j'ai pas dix
quinze minutes le temps assez
significative et beaucoup de jeux call
est de 7
ça nous a tous surpris ça nous a tous
surpris et plutôt agréablement prennent
accablement bon ok paraît-il que il peut
par exemple paraît-il qui ont ils ne
nous pas assez de la pression sur f2
enfin il veut continuer toujours élevé
les veut dire cohérent simon les noirs
vu le dire qu'ils ont enfin il a inspiré
peut-être que des quatre n'est pas si
bien
je pense parce qu'il a pensé qu'il ya eu
deux cédé 2,5 et qu'on voit les les 2,5
pas trop d'activités pour les pièces
blanches les tournois sont liés vous là
que la faiblesse sur quatre et ça va je
pense qu'une fois
moi si un joueur des cats rapidement je
pense qu'il a compris que le problème
s'est passé des épreuves de ski après ed
que le d4
le cavalier va se promener 5 et ya un
problème avec les pros société s il faut
défendre un ou l'autre au milieu d'eux
on est à prévoir dans la partie derrière
donc on va forcément encore je pense que
peut-être en juin une ligne avec
laquelle n'était pas très familiers je
pense que peut-être il n'était pas trop
au courant de décider des bois j'ai
inventé les a été mon impression pendant
les passions donc après des cadres il
s'est remis de nouveaux jeux à réfléchir
il avait juste à noter que au lieu de 10
4 selon le directeur ce que l'audience
qu'intéressant cp4 avec l'idée à
broadway et après les 20 pouces
mais bon que possible possible mais moi
ce que j'aurais fait de ces cartes quand
même très logique c'est l'idée de base
tu prends le sang et puis tu soulignes
un peu les cavaliers qui sont mal
passées parce qu'ils touchent plus il
touche pas les pions blancs si tu veux à
partir du haut dernier recours à cavaler
deux sets et en continuant avec les
coûts à venir
je doute chaque roue douchka ici moi par
exemple je pense que tout est fluide
par exemple si tu joues dans votre moi
par exemple j'ai eu des ici que les de
katako les cinq sets
oui je touche la balle rien d'un trou et
si tu reprends avec le pion ceinture
je connaissais cisco exemple est ici de
sang que les peaux 4 avicole et ce cinq
bon tu sautes de partout et aux 1,6 donc
tous réussis 2e 2e dans trois ou quatre
ans le pion est pas vraiment pris ici
parce que la dame de la dame se ferait
toucher c'est quand même important
oui bien sûr donc par exemple dans deux
trois ans
si on analyse ça quand les jocistes d'un
message collé ce soir avec l'idée d'en
but à 5 dans nos cinq damas a collé son
entourage et il récupère à 4 et un sac
tir où on saute sur trois surfe khadra
falloir d'activité a beaucoup
d'activités pour le pion à moins d'un v6
pour moi c'est pas sûr que le thème
mieux possible ça tapait sur le centre
ou et sentent presque sans réfléchir
maximum le poids du corps les trois
foyers bien jouer puisqu'il retouches
les cases importants ou et de toute
façon c'est surtout de saint-crescent
qui restent qui intéresse les bois tout
est fluide sous couleur je veux pas
critiquer d'améliorer dance 2 il prépare
torah d un maxi mais il veut petit à
petit mettre un petit inconvénient et
fils en effet il veut faire monter sa
position tu disais il serait peut-être
torah d un g3 roi g2 les petit à petit
après carénage quatre griefs 5 pourquoi
pas jouer petit à petit prendre et de
l'espace est immonde d'une ligne quoi
quand tu voyages et en russe as-tu
watney a choisi monte monte vrai sens à
ses montées la position monter les
positions du monde lorsque mon temps la
position vous vous gagner de l'espace
errance a pu se terminer par les
mouvements de l'adversaire ce qui sera
le cas
d'ailleurs pendant la transmission j'ai
recommandé deux parties sur ce jeu sur
un lit même structure et les mortiers
sur l'échiquier
la première c'était
carson a dance with 15e plus ok l'année
et le deuxième c'était amende à regarde
jouer autour notre candidat à moscou si
le sujet vous intéresse comment monter
une interdiction un gagné a pu analyser
ces deux là et elles sont d'exemplaires
et je pense que maintenant c'est un
autre point tournant très important
s'est partiellement parce que pendant le
live ce qu'on disait c'est que la
difficulté de mamediarov ça a été ça
allait de jouer avec peu d espace et de
réussir à attendre et de surtout pas
craqué en juin prend des quatre îles et
réfléchi pendant longtemps il a pris sur
2,4 en est persuadé qu'ils se sont faute
parce que n'oublions pas les noirs
échangent leur pion central sur 2,5 pour
le pion des quatre mais qu'est ce qu'il
nous reste
il ne reste que le clan de 4 est plus
actif que des sifi energia a native nous
faut aller aussi bien sûr des cats et ça
ça ressemble beaucoup aux écossaises
genre tu vas pouvoir jouer un jour en
monte en pression avec f 4g quatre
cachets droite fait même un jour j'ai 5
ou f 5.5 à l'occasion des fauves yann
libre et savoir parler pendant la partie
sinon le cavalier il vise même pas f 5 5
il est quand même biologie retrait 5e 5
qui visent toutes les cases importante
sur la cinquième rang j'ai donc bien sûr
au lieu de haute et il a fallu quand
même garder les quoi sert ce jeu je
collais j6m en effet g3 et puis au récit
c'est ok c'est déjà plus grand secret
c'est moins bien que tout à l'heure mais
ce n'est pas ce point - voire opposées
aux vents vont certes rente
ça dépasse pas eu des donc à notre pour
un tournant que l'étiquette et je
considère le prochain coup de chaque
canal à combien d'autres fautes n'ont
pas encore je pense presque presque pas
mis à entre les ordinateurs set décisif
déjà intervenu moins pas encore donc il
a joué
ah non c'est bien trop il fallait jouer
cavalier avis et continuer la pratique
religieuse par exemple bien sûr il n'a
pas failli à cause du cor les besoins
auprès d'hommes sait si ce taux à venir
car la justice
j'ai trouvé rien de trop grave pour le
nord ok je gêne quelque chose comme ça
bien sûr après corps et si les noirs
sont moins bien et les blancs ou
plusieurs façons de jouer à part de cor
les besoins
mais dans tous les cas s'affaiblir avec
les dents sur 1,6 s'affaiblir de nouveau
dans les situations comme les cavaliers
blanc vizquel 5 après quoi déçu par
huissier le verset 6 est tout à fait
bien le pion des six alors que les
blancs veulent juste mettre une tour sur
des 1 et se jeter par tous et elana
moral est complètement coupé du jeu
c'est l'histoire de curé une maladie
avec eux une maladie encore plus grave
ouais donc quand l'edf
maxime josse très concrète concrètement
par le cavalier rêve ça commence à
provoquer des grosses menaces et
maintenant aussi comme plat de la dia le
pion des six qui en l'air maintenant si
les noix cherche à ramener la dame km2
le jour et joue par exemple coller ce
sera liquidée d'amd 3e tour atteint
empêche que relève 5 avril sonne le fion
donc de 5,5 d'un v6 alors c'est très
typique 1 quand on a cette structure de
pions avec le pion des 6 contre le pur 4
sur d525 pour préparer après être quatre
à mener la dame et jouer de la wamu
l'auto la majorité allèles où il ya
toujours trois tours j'ai trois mais
jouer pour cette majorité a les droits
et ya même parfois ça se transforme en
f4 f5 investissent aussi cas c'est très
dangereux dans un bon signe mais après
rouages dos les problèmes restent parce
que à ouakam m
sow lancé à l'attaqué un moment donné
mais ça a été quand même mieux que dans
la partie ouest quand même la dame
recommence de participer aux joueurs de
bouger pendant les 3 et 4 en 1 4 je
voulais sur la 4e tandis que je crée au
lieu de 6 à la casse des six sur le roi
faible mais bon ça joue encore il a joué
comme les six tours à des orateurs et
que les souris et les caris & vie c'est
juste bizarre parce qu'il est assassin
tiré beaucoup après ok il y avait une
proposition d'ordinateurs dames 2 2 avec
les vicieuses faire qu'ils essaient 3gsm
cavalli f5 échec et d'emprunts agissent
et pour ça tout ça pour ça tu ressembles
pour l'empêcher moi je pense que même
après la partie je préfère toujours là
franchement le choix dominé j'avais en
moi
il protège le point 4 il prépare juste
d'un même de dames g3 qui tapera sur des
six ont refait un clin d'oeil je croyais
et sur g3 et agissent toutes les
faiblesses et tu auras tu en as le
parfait duo d'un cavalier la dame qui
attaquera les deux cases avec le
canadien mais il faut dire que les noirs
ont beaucoup cherché pour pendant cinq
six boules et noir ont beaucoup cherché
à détruire mes bras je pense que les
photos décisive parce que si tu as les
parties de jouer de sa hockey déjà josé
pierre par force presque avant sa paire
du matériel pas si d'un v6 euros achat
dans ce set d'un mode 2d 5 maintenant
c'est encore calme jouable dès que vous
les dix ans que les 2,5 tournera dans le
vent c'est des gens ne les aident à
mascate m6 dame de 4,7 dégueulasse mais
les noirs père par céder grass que le
pion isolé il est vraiment c'est
dégueulasse mans un peu de terrain par
exemple je sais pas peut-être entrer
dans une fenêtre de toit avec un pion du
mois
avec l'activité autour je sais pas mais
quelque chose de ce genre n'oublions pas
r33 rendent le haut fourneau le haut des
droits mais un peu grâce à 5 6 points
comme il peut y avoir des perpète il
peut y avoir des trous et ça peut encore
un peu joué mais les noix sont meilleurs
mais la foi nous absolument arriver
n'est le dans deux jours après sur
d'imbéciles gens disent que ce n'est pas
le seul coup peut-être des rêves de
direct aussi jouable bien sûr mais des
cinq tout de suite d'un meuble de bain
le problème annoncé les menace d'alger 3
et comment faire puisque après quoi pas
que dans 17 mois chez les ménages et
donc mais en plus y'a le pion des cinq
qui va tomber
oui parce que maintenant on va là c'est
de prendre si il aurait essayé
d'échanger lecavalier
les landais cavalcade je pense que le
plus facile se joue déjà vlad ça fait
aucun sens ce qui avait recueilli suite
aux coups précédents
ouais mais le pire des systèmes plus
haut à meyrin que je pense que le plus
simple ce sans réfléchir aux simples que
vous alliez de cette dame je crois pour
les jeux 6 h 14
4h qu'attaché d'ordinateurs et 4
seulement voilà c'est un peu tout et f4
human h4 si romain non mais c'est
horrible à doit faire car et des 6 7 5
le roi le roi est juste c'est quasiment
impossible à défendre vlad howe est
juste un instant s'il vous plaît mais tu
peux même pas faire car il ya tout ce
que tu as car il est des six quand même
qui enferme la truite pâturages 600
l'air ok mais sur g6 la dia il ya même
hacker prend et ouvrir kane soleil quand
les os 6 je veux dire l'ordinateur dont
deux victoires bras après h4 ou le 2 4
sur ce je les comprends
à 5 pour les jeux cette voie je sais que
les 5 et 6 roy s'est déjà mise en jeu
cinq six voire huit au lieu d'ouvrir
cette réussite mais c'est marc moins bon
c'est le choix
oui donc et sur g6 quel point facebook
plus simple si j'avais compris f4 qui
doit gagner aussi d'ailleurs ce que la
position est juste tellement
catastrophique mais oui tu prends juste
failli a rien à faire en fait pour
défendre
or pas c'est toujours les mêmes
situations qui attend des pièces qui
attaque et elles vont être temps de plus
d'espacé et
et voilà donc il a joué à tous
réussissent pour blinder les case la
case h six mois son problème c'est
qu'après d'un je crois qu est le seul
coup maintenant ses cavaliers 8 c'est
pour ça qu'on me dit que ça permet un
pion tout à l'heure parce que le pion g7
est attaqué et surgissent issa qui prend
un fils dont on n'a pas trop le choix
ouais juin 9-6 non parce que 6 accor
lâche 5 il ya damage quatre cavaliers
vie si c'est par exemple le 5-5 collège
ça suffit
bref il que les hfc et des enfants tout
gagner quoi ici tout non mais c'est
difficile d'analyser parce que je sais
juste visuels en fallait donc d'argent
trois corps de huit et maintenant donc
c'est un pion de gens parce que maxime a
pris sur des cinq heures d'ailleurs moi
pendant les parties j'ai dit qu aujourd
hui être agréé ce temps là je refais le
5-4 et des carrières exercice l'attak
aides directes je suis sûre même -
maxime c'est une autre génération
peut-être plus pragmatique que c'est
l'ancien curé eds d'écoles et de centres
en france qui se dit juste qu'il gagne
en option un coeur et domination de
cavaliers dominical - il est vrai la
dame assise comme c'est un peu on peut
redevenir l'on sait si ce qui a disparu
d'un match 4 biensure l'idc c'est ok ce
match typique en fait l'idée c'est
aurons d'autres autour de sa ferme à une
pièce de 8,8 dans ma tête il n'y a pas
d'injustice parce que pour une seule
attaque et surtout l'âme 6 kg cette
fourchette
oui et donc si leur fille d'alors et
sirois lui qui ce problème ainsi qu
auprès d'intesa
déjà c'est un pion lui ce cavalier
dominé les noirs peuvent pas éviter les
pertes de deuxième pion parce que dans 2
8 en deux sets et donc les noirs doivent
de la deuxième plus longue mais j'arrive
à faire un échec 1 bis si un jour le
cygne noir ou argent et je suis je pense
que c'est mon ordinateur collège système
auquel on menace mais attend plus
bon ok c'est complètement fou tu
redonnes dans tous les cas avec un pion
de pouce même avec deux un corpus cloud
donc il ajoutant 17 qui était le coup
qui nous semblait le plus résistant live
aussi oui oui et madame qui a joué un
petit coussin pas il a fait car ils
étaient trois quarts elle y était plus
ou moins dans l'air l'eau la tendresse
sur a6 et la tossée russie il veut juste
prendre le contrôle de la colonne
d'ailleurs et en plus comme ça et le roi
réagir projet donc cavalier seul des six
wickets dans les mauvaises positions
tous les coups sont mauvais selon
l'ancienne aire expression que les deux
cas maintenant si tous eu un set c'était
possible encore tout continue comme les
202 euros tout rond
entre nous je parle vite les noirs sont
foutus au moins pour toujours mais je
criais m'a laissé l'impression de tête à
essayer de terminer la partie vidéo
j'ai eu cette impression de là parce que
ni les conquois en étant sûr qu'il va
les perdre
il allait s'y fier sans fil et non une
fois qu'il était perdant il a laissé là
où plus de 2000 était incapable de
réfléchir
tout ça parce qu'il est réussie de
perdre harcelé dans quelques mains juste
pourtant c'était possible encore de très
neuf ans voire cinq ans je suis
persuadée de ressemble qu'à voler
jusqu'à maintenant bon siège autour pop
entourant le problème c'est que les
artistes qui arrivent
au col de st donc il a préféré jouer
autour de 55 hockey
parce que après tour de cinq ans de
sangatte du matériel tout de suite si
florence la tour 6-7 collége ici menace
bien évidemment découverte ici dans ce
16e riad de 8 qui arrive avec deux
cavaliers de cette donne jean retour
série j'aurais regardé bon live qui est
décédé cheikh roi g8 tourcoing 8 échecs
cavaliers prend et d'enfoncer 8 avec une
pièce de plus voilà l'égalisation
ouais bah victoire assez facile de
maxime très facile aussi par mois à
savoir parmi les plus faciles dans sa
vie de rhji facile que celle de sharjah
rien au final mans ouais sharma ça s'est
reflété et félicitations à maxime et à
son équipe pour avoir bien trouvé
l'ouverture dans laquelle shahriyar
allait mal joué peut-être que la
variante est pas la plus intéressante
d'un point de vue théorique pour les
blancs mais qu'est ce que ce n'est rien
et c'est à dire cela paradoxalement
pendant ouais là c'est vraiment convenu
comme un gant quoi il s'est fait juste
balayé donc non seulement rapide que tu
es aujourd'hui au jury mais à 14 heures
pour la grande finale allait tout
s'avère france toutes les francophonies
derrière max pies sonore